the winner of the voice is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kelly yeah back-to-back like would Judah
Adam and should Adam and Blake even show
up
yes I love them yes they should no I
literally I was telling her in the car
was like I believed like she totally had
the power to win I obviously believed in
there since the blinds but it's so hard
to one get country people on your team
if you're not like Shelton
no one's ever beat him with a country
heart I don't even know what to say
right now and now obviously the first
question is how does it feel and now
that you're the winner over here in the
gold hat over here in the gold hat I'm
shocked I'm very blessed very blessed
and super excited I love you
she is gonna make the most amazing her
record is still number one her original
song not a cover y'all her original song
is still number one on iTunes that's
just something people people love it I'm
excited
does this open a spot for her on tour
and would you want to tour with Kelly
well my first thing I just told her in
the car too is peep the writers of the
song are so excited like it's going so
well and like just so you'll know like
the writers love song or amazing writers
one of them specifically is written like
a billion number ones in country music
like he is a phenomenal writer and
friend of mine Shay McInally so I'm I'm
hoping to hook her up first of all I
want to make sure that it's exactly her
sound I know she loves Loretta and Dolly
and she loves that old school and there
is totally way we can make her sound
work nowadays I want to thank Chris
Stapleton Kacey Musgraves all the people
bringing back that old vibe of country
music enabling us to do that so but I
want to make sure she makes the record
she wants to make before she goes on the
road you know you want to make sure your
style is you and I understand that more
than anyone I had to fight really hard
after I want to make sure it was me so
I'm gonna do that for you
Samoan Entertainment Tonight yeah
Elliott that is good okay go sorry you
talked a bunch about how much you texted
an email brain after Siwon so Chanel are
you ready to have Kelly as a momager now
oh I am
like my team calls me that by the way
they never did that with bran but with
her they're like you need to calm down
like you're like singing the words and
doing like I I think I am a momager
I love it I'm sorry I already text you
so much I'm sorry okay I love it I'm
like oh mom Kelly takes really oh good
because I'm like I'll always look at my
husband I'm like is this too much I love
this long Texas everyday I just want to
make I that what and I always say this
just probably knowing who that but I
just wanted to make sure the whole time
she's having fun like even at 36 years
old it is so hard sometimes not just in
this industry in any industry to just
have fun at what you're doing and who
you're working with and and I know that
sounds like a mom thing to say but it it
is true and so I always texted her and
I'm like make sure you have fun like you
know some days you're gonna be awesome
some days you're gonna suck and it's you
know you try your best
right so it's I just wanted to have a
good time and that's what art should be
it should be fun and enjoyable great
what kind of advice has been given you
during your journey if any at all I
don't know if y'all hung out
specifically together because friends
been in my house Brent and ready to
remember in my house so um I don't think
y'all have seen each other but I will
tell you what the one thing that she
loves I can say this because burns told
me this but um is is she Brinn loves you
know what everybody loves transparency
and you love that you can like see
exactly there are it's very authentic
it's fishy is unique she stands out like
there's there's a lot of people that can
sing country music but not a lot of
people that are countries like they they
literally they exude they're almost born
like coming out of the way I'm sounding
like a little redolent it's like crazy
it's and it's honestly as a country
music fan from childhood like I love
contemporary country too obviously I'm a
fan I've done Jewett so people I'm just
saying there is an element that I do
dearly miss about country music that it
will one women there's like two of them
on the charts but and also it's just the
fact that it's and I know I want to
actually expand upon that because a lot
of those women changed my life like Reba
Trisha faith Martina Patty The Judds why
no no when she went alone like all these
women changed my life as a singer and I
that's I think that's why I got so teary
eyed like watching her
last night is it's like we need that
like those there needs to have little
girls need people in every genre of
music to look up to and to like admire
and to like aspire to be and and all of
them gonna cry again I feel like there's
an element missing and she when she when
I turn for her in the blinds I mean I
remember I think I even mentioned dolly
when I hadn't turned it I think I did
yeah I was like dolly it's like
something like it's like something
that's rare you know and and I think
that's what's so amazing about her and
the opportunity that she represents for
not only women but like just do the
original sound of country you know and I
don't know and I love it I know people
always like your pop well yeah but I
love all genres like you know and you're
allowed to yeah it's like you're not
invited they used to tell me that junior
high too but I still came haha but you
get rid of me we'd be Blake Shelton of
the country artists y'all your kids
wanted to go on a reality singing
competition show how would you feel cuz
I I found out for some reason I wasn't a
stage mom written but I feel like I have
been with her like I literally like my
senses laughing like their cuz i layer
literally like you need to call me like
but I get so excited and I'm afraid of
what kind of mom I would be I'm afraid
like I mean I know I'd be supportive but
like would I be the mom that's like I
think I'd be my mom well it was good you
know what I'm saying like I think you
know my mom like and I loved it I think
that's why I'm such a hard worker and
why I aspire to like keep pushing myself
I love my mom for it but I I think I
mean I've heard better but it was solid
yeah like and I don't have to do that I
hope they're like t-shirts or doctors or
something I don't know it's a hard
industry
I warned Brendan's mom I'm her mom I'm
like you know hold on to him hug him
tell him really nice things cuz people
are mean uh-huh
that's horrible but that's a reality
when did you know that you could win and
why did you want to win like
you know I I never really knew exactly
when I knew I could win I've just I
wanted to get as far as I could and just
show the world whose Chevelle is on the
show as far as I made it and so here I
am sitting and I won not winning because
the universe heard you and heard all the
other ones go like you know yeah I just
I think about what I've always had some
belief in me and I've always wanted to
do this so no matter how far I made it I
was gonna be happy but here I am and I'm
I'm happy so it's awesome